[Aplausos]
[Música]
bernie sanders no existe o la crisis de
el coronavirus da un vuelco totalmente
inesperado a las primarias del partido
demócrata o el nombre de bernie sanders
no pasará a la historia a pesar de ello
lo cierto es que sanders es como la
fuerza de la gravedad es decir es un
tipo que siempre ha estado ahí atrayendo
hacia la izquierda al partido demócrata
con la misma fuerza que la gravedad hizo
caer la manzana sobre la cabeza de
newton y amigos hoy por hoy ese puede
ser el gran triunfo de sanders hacer que
algunas de sus propuestas sean adoptadas
por yo bailé
[Aplausos]
ahora bien un momento esto no será
posible es y luego finalmente joe biden
no derrota al presidente trump y para
lograrlo el histórico senador de
delaware y más tarde dice presidente con
barack obama tendrá que sumar fuerzas
con el resto del partido demócrata y eso
eso va a ser más que complicado con
sanders un político que siempre ha
presumido de ser un independiente y si
no que se lo digan a hillary clinton así
que la pregunta es quién es bernie
sanders cuánto lleva en política que
defiende y lo que es más importante
porque muchos candidatos se han retirado
en las primarias sólo para evitar que
este tipo sea el candidato demócrata
amigos en visual político hoy vamos a
dar respuesta a todas estas preguntas
pero antes antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia media vida en la política
[Música]
donde estabas en 1981 vosotros no lo sé
pero yo por ejemplo ni siquiera había
nacido aún me faltaban unos cuantos años
para aterrizar en este mundo el que sí
sabemos dónde estaba es bernie sanders
hace ni más ni menos que 39 años
empezaba su vida política como alcalde
de burlington una pequeña ciudad del
estado de vermont
seguro que por entonces nadie imaginaba
que después de ocho años como alcalde
sería congresista durante 16 años y más
tarde senador por otros 18 si finalmente
llega a agotar su actual mandato que
termina en 2025
permiso antes nació en brooklyn nueva
york en 1941 apenas tres meses antes del
ataque japonés a pearl harbor fue el
segundo hijo de una familia de
inmigrantes polacos de origen judío la
religión se ha preocupado un lugar
secundario en su vida posteriormente
estudió ciencias políticas en la
universidad de chicago por cierto una
universidad privada donde pronto empezó
su carrera como activista
y que podía hacer un joven activista en
los eeuu de los años 60 y 70 pues
participar a favor de dos causas que
marcaron a toda una generación el
movimiento por los derechos civiles
donde sanders luchó activamente contra
la segregación racial en la universidad
y el movimiento pacifista que se
movilizaba entonces contra la guerra de
vietnam y es que vamos a ver si y
sanders tiene un carácter arrollador con
78 años ni imaginable con 40 tacos menos
pues bien digamos que toda esa energía y
toda la labor política que desarrolló en
vermont durante los años 70 le llevaron
en 1981 a derrotar al partido demócrata
que llevaba 16 años dirigiendo la ciudad
de burlington sí sí habéis escuchado
bien derrotó al partido demócrata porque
amigos sanders se presentó como
independiente era ahí es un
independiente porque siempre le ha
gustado lo de ir por libre y eso explica
que hoy en día encontramos titulares
como éste
bernie sanders bajo escrutinio por
apoyar a los andinistas en la década de
1980 el caso es que la alcaldía de
burlington fue su trampolín para llegar
a la cámara de representantes- como
independiente y muy pronto quedó claro
que había llegado a la política de
washington para quedarse un tipo llamado
adolf hitler ganó una elección en 1932 y
50 millones de personas murieron como
resultado de esa lección en la segunda
guerra mundial de incluidos 6 millones
de judíos entonces lo que aprendí de
pequeño es que la política es de hecho
muy importante
bernie sanders y claro se lo que estáis
pensando pero vamos a ver enrique como
que ver mis under es un independiente si
está peleando por liderar a los
demócratas por segunda vez pues vamos a
ver si me explico y me contáis que os
parece la estrategia política de verne
mirad desde 1990 se ha presentado hasta
en diez ocasiones a las primarias del
partido demócrata de vermont a las
primarias para los candidatos a la
cámara de representantes y a los
candidatos al senado y si algo queda
claro es que sanders va por libre
en cuatro de esas diez ocasiones la
última en 2004 sanders perdió las
primarias demócratas de vermont pero no
os equivoquéis ese revés no cambiaba sus
planes luego se presentaban las
elecciones como independiente y ganaba
el cargo frente a los candidatos
republicanos y demócratas
lo más curioso es que sanders actúa
exactamente igual cuando gana las
primarias siempre rechaza la nominación
y se presenta como independiente dejando
a los demócratas sin candidato oficial
es decir para entendernos que a lo largo
de los años pues ha utilizado al partido
demócrata como una mera plataforma para
amplificar su mensaje
pero lo que más critican de sus ya
largos 30 años en washington es otra
cuestión veréis durante estas décadas
los demócratas han tenido durante 16
años el gobierno federal 8 años con 1000
clinton y 8 años con barack obama pues
bien en todo este tiempo es ander sólo
ha sido el patrocinador principal de
siete proyectos de ley que finalmente se
convirtieron en ley las dos más
destacadas que impulsados anders han
mejorado las compensaciones a veteranos
de guerra pero amigos el resto el resto
son por así decirlo un poco pintorescas
dos leyes sirvieron para cambiar el
nombre de dos oficinas de correo postal
en vermont otra para avalar un acuerdo
sobre el suministro de agua entre
vermont y nunca la protección de una
zona de los apalaches y la celebración
del bicentenario de vermont vamos que la
labor legislativa de bernie pues no ha
sido precisamente un avance de la gran
revolución que ahora propugna para todos
los eeuu
ahora bien tampoco seamos injustos el
trabajo de un congresista o de un
senador va mucho más allá de las leyes
que haya podido impulsar está por
ejemplo su contribución al debate
público y lo que más llama la atención
es que he cumplido los 70 cuando la
lógica señala a los políticos el camino
de la jubilación haya sido entonces
cuando bernie sanders ha cobrado un
protagonismo inesperado y la pregunta es
qué pasó para que sandler dirá el salto
a la primera plana pues la crisis
económica
el sobresalto de gritos reclusión en el
viaje en busca de poner entonces ante su
estado
amigos cuando barack obama llegó al
poder en el año 2009 eeuu estaba en
plena gran recesión y lo cierto es que
la gestión de la administración obama no
gustó a todo el mundo especialmente a la
más radical de la izquierda
norteamericana y entonces entonces
emergieron algunos movimientos potentes
como por ejemplo el occupied wall
street'
y la pregunta es tiempo ya dar una
respuesta política por la izquierda a
esas manifestaciones populares que
clamaban contra los poderes económicos
evidentemente estos movimientos no
querían saber nada de republicanos ni de
demócratas así que si alguien podría
representarles ese era bernie sanders el
senador independiente de vermont
y aquí es donde nace la candidatura de
sanders a las primarias presidenciales
de la misma forma que al otro lado del
ring político surgió con fuerza la
figura de ron paul
en este escenario indicó méxico una
candidatura la de sanders que surgió de
un círculo de fieles muy potentes un
círculo muy fiel tan fiel como
insuficiente para conseguir el respaldo
mayoritario del partido demócrata
ahora bien llegados a este punto creo
que tenemos que dar un giro argumental y
responder a una pregunta a la pregunta
que lleva sobrevolando las primarias
demócratas del 2020 porque los tipos que
mandan en el partido demócrata los tipos
más influyentes lo que se conoce como el
establishment no quieren ver ni en
pintura sanders atentos
un socialista en américa
comunista
y socialdemócrata
a estas alturas puede que os preguntéis
alegal enrique pero qué demonios
defiende bernie sanders pues digamos que
él se autodefine como un socialista
democrático
'no con su debut en swing y aquí hay una
cosa que no podemos obviar amigos tras
décadas de guerra fría contra la unión
soviética decir en eeuu que de
socialista es tan impopular como decir
en el hollywood de 2020 que descolgada
de harvey weinstein como todos ya sabéis
desde hace muchas décadas en eeuu
el socialismo se suele considerar como
una ideología anti americana y la verdad
es que va a ser complicado que se quite
esa etiqueta de encima con sanders
haciendo declaración
cómo estás sanders bin justo limitarse a
decir que todo lo de la cuba de fidel
castro es malo ya os podéis imaginar
como sentó esta defensa del régimen
castrista en florida donde hillary
clinton perdió por un punto contra
donald trump pero también en el resto de
los eeuu porque claro con cualquier
político pues hoy y siempre se puede
pensar que unas palabras así pues han
sido un desliz pero claro cuando las
pronuncia bernie sanders que pasó su
luna de miel en la unión soviética de
los años 80 pues entonces la cosa cambia
[Música]
y amigos este es el motivo por el que
tanto el establishment del partido
demócrata como los sectores moderados de
la política norteamericana pues le
tienen alergia a bernie sanders
pero en fin el caso es que hasta ahora
nos hemos centrado mucho en la
trayectoria de sanders pero que puede
ofrecer su socialismo democrático y
seguro a youtube el software ahora no
son people
camps volver a ser del iris interior de
wikileaks y poder como revolution
el incentivo que impartiendo poder de
compras en el wikreate globalmente works
fuego
el principal objetivo del programa de
bernie sanders es luchar contra la
desigualdad para ello promete llevar a
cabo grandes revoluciones para reducir
la pobreza garantizar una educación
pública de calidad matrículas
universitarias completamente gratuitas
perdonar la deuda estudiantil sanidad
pública y gratuita para todo el mundo y
descarbonizar la economía para que
estados unidos lidere la lucha contra el
cambio climático
nos recuerda algo sí exacto es todo lo
contrario a lo que tradicionalmente han
sido los eeuu por ejemplo algunas
medidas que propone para combatir la
desigualdad son tan radicales que
nosotros vería con ellas ni la
socialdemocracia europea
en el sampling hindúes sociedad anónima
del bolsón sordo socialismo de hollywood
life my one sin el tema del fire frank
eso se desprende con mi tema que se
magnéticamente
veréis me explicó a asegurarse de que
las empresas paguen los impuestos que
les corresponden pues está muy bien
subir el impuesto de sociedades- que
trabajo es una opción vale te puede no
gustar pero hoy es una opción y si
tenemos en cuenta el enorme déficit en
las cuentas públicas que va a dejar
trump pues incluso podría sonar
razonable aunque no a mí me sigue sin
gustar la idea
ahora bien obligar a las empresas a
acceder un 20% de sus acciones a los
trabajadores parece más una expropiación
de la venezuela de maduro que una medida
de la españa de felipe gonzález
y luego está el tema sanitario una
propuesta que de repente se ha
encontrado con el momento idóneo para
estar sobre la mesa y es que la crisis
de coronavirus pues puede hacer a los
estadounidenses más sensibles a su
medicare for all
sanders propone extender el programa
público medicare que garantiza la
atención sanitaria a ancianos y
discapacitados a todas las personas
incluidas los inmigrantes su objetivo es
que el sistema sanitario estadounidense
se parezca más a un modelo europeo sin
embargo lo más polémico de su propuesta
es que asegura que prohibir a los
seguros privados de salud lo que por
supuesto ni siquiera ocurre en europa
amigos amigas básicamente todo el
discurso de sanders pasa por multiplicar
el gasto público hacer que el estado
crezca como si no hubiera mañana y
prometer grandes revoluciones
y esto esto nos lleva a otro gran
problema que tiene bernie sanders como
piensa pagar toda esta fiesta
la teoría monetaria moderna
vamos a hacer rápidamente unos números
tan solo medicare for all costaría unos
47 millones de dólares al año cuando el
total del presupuesto de gastos
federales de 4,4 millones
así que siendo generosos llevar a cabo
todas las propuestas de sanders
supondría como mínimo duplicar el gasto
público y eso como mínimo la pregunta es
cómo soluciona este candidato este
problema
pues bien aparentemente subiendo
impuestos y proponiendo la creación de
otros nuevos tributos wow no parece la
mejor carta de presentación para ir a
unas elecciones verdad
sin embargo lo que más asusta a la vieja
guardia del partido demócrata es esto la
economista que cree que el gobierno
debería imprimir más dinero la asesora
de bernie sanders stefanic elton
argumenta que como lo pagaremos no
debería ser una pregunta central en la
política estadounidense stephanie kelton
lleva cinco años colaborando
estrechamente con bernie sanders es una
gran defensora de la teoría monetaria
moderna un movimiento que básicamente
propone que los gobiernos que controlan
su propia moneda pues puedan gastar
libremente prácticamente sin límite ya
que hoy es siempre pueden imprimir más y
más billetes para pagar sus deudas
la teoría monetaria moderna sugiere que
el gasto público puede incrementarse
creando más dinero hasta conseguir que
la economía alcance su máxima capacidad
y elimina el desempleo así se podrían
financiar programas importantes como la
sanidad universal la matrícula
universitaria gratuita o la energía
verde
la tradición económica vincula la idea
de imprimir billetes sin control con la
hiperinflación sin embargo la teoría
monetaria moderna defiende que el
aumento del gasto público no generará
inflación mientras exista desempleo es
decir mano de obra que demande un puesto
de trabajo con el que empezar a producir
suena bien pues si queréis ver los
resultados de toda esta historia no
tenéis más que haceros un viaje por la
argentina porque amigos esto es
básicamente lo que llevan haciendo los
políticos argentinos desde hace décadas
querido y si no la ponen los empresarios
quien cree que la pongas y hablar con el
estado es lo que yo animo a ver de dónde
quieren que la hagamos como sostenemos
esto
lo cierto es que incluso dando por buena
esta teoría lo cual ya es mucho decir su
margen de actuación sería en todo caso
muy limitado la economía de eeuu se
caracteriza por tener un mercado laboral
muy dinámico de tal forma que el
desempleo estructural es muy reducido
técnicamente muy cercano a la situación
de pleno empleo pero eso no es todo como
os hemos dicho antes para financiar
todas sus revoluciones políticas y al
mismo tiempo impedir la inflación que
podría ocasionar toda esta emisión de
nuevo dinero lo que sanders defiende es
subir impuestos subir todos los
impuestos crean nuevos impuestos y una
vez creados volverlos a subir
pero qué ocurre si incluso con tantos
nuevos impuestos las cuentas no cuadran
la asesora de bernie sanders dice que
eeuu puede agregar de manera segura
500.000 millones al déficit en otras
palabras
sanders quiere acabar con lo que
históricamente han sido los eeuu sueña y
defiende una revolución popular que
podría terminar creando algo así como
los eeuu socialistas de américa si creo
que esa definición le haría sentirse
cómodo
seguro que ahora ya entendéis porque
bernie sanders genera tanto miedo en el
establishment norteamericano y también
porque es under sería el candidato
favorito del mismísimo donald trump que
oye por supuesto otra cosa muy diferente
es que luego terminase llegando al poder
e hiciese lo mismo que hizo como durante
sus años en el congreso y el senado
prácticamente nada el caso es que las
primarias empezaron bastante bien para
este candidato pero la tendencia es de
supermartes es favorable a yo bailé
desde el momento en el que la carrera de
la nominación quedó reducida a dos
opciones cada vez parece más claro que
va a ir en va a ser finalmente la
persona escogida por el partido
demócrata para luchar contra donald
trump tal y como os hemos explicado las
propuestas de sandler en principio le
pueden sonar bien a muchas personas
especialmente a los jóvenes a todos los
que arrastran enormes préstamos
universitarios y a quienes sufren los
quebraderos de cabeza del sistema
sanitario americano
pero amigos su receta económica combina
de forma peligrosa los conceptos de
déficit impuestos e inflación un cóctel
explosivo que explica que prácticamente
todos los candidatos de las primarias
demócratas
excepto elisabeth warren hayan dejado
vía libre a joe biden para concentrar
cuanto antes el voto moderado
en fin pronto veremos si el coronavirus
da una nueva oportunidad a las
propuestas sanitarias de sanders pero
ahora ahora el turno es para ti estoy de
acuerdo con el programa electoral de
este candidato y la forma de financiar
sus propuestas dejadnos vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios y ya
sabéis si este vídeo se resultó
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros avisa al político si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho en fin una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]